so this whole idea of not being
monogamous and non-monogamous or
whatever the case may be that's a very
you know elongated process but and this
is why marriage is necessary right
especially when you're talking about
someone who has access to wealth wealth
represents choice right you can make as
many choices as quick and as fast as you
can you can replicate yourself all these
different things so it comes apart in
marriage often does that it's
unfortunate when it does it because now
this means that i'm willing to
restrict some of the creative energy
that i feel from other people right i'm
gonna limit that creative expression i'm
not going to take the crit cause i work
with men all the time i work and i don't
sleep with my clients and i don't you
know do all this kind of stuff do we
creatively express ourselves and get to
get you know what i'm saying but it's
hype they're attractive i'm attractive
whatever the case may be but it doesn't
always mean that you take the energy
that you feel from another person and
you sexualize it you don't always have
to do that with energy especially when
you have a family right when you have a
family and a part of your income is a
part of giving stability to you know
your offspring so you have to begin to
think beyond just yourself right if
you're thinking just about yourself you
can do whatever you want to do with your
creative energy but if you care about
how you replicate yourself in the form
of children then this has to change
right so it's not don't you wish you sat
you down and talked to you about it yeah
it's so right so you're always going to
feel creative energy i i have no
attraction to women i don't sexually
want to be with them but do i creatively
respond to someone who has intelligence
who have beauty and have art and
expression yes but it doesn't mean that
i take that relationship and i sexualize
it and what part of it and then what
part of it do i need to sexualize it for
it to be mine for me to have a part of
it so you you and and this is why i
argue a wealthy man uh
has to love his wife right a a woman
that is with a man she she she making
get away in that marriage without her
actually loving him if he's wealthy she
could get away with that she can you
know have children she can do this she
can do that he cannot do that because if
he doesn't absolutely love her to the
degree that he understands that his love
is supporting a family he's going to
constantly tap that creative energy in a
way that is going to deploy that family
that's the issue with it you're always
going to feel creative energy between
people you're going to feel it but if a
wealthy woman
doesn't for example if you flip the
situation if a wealthy woman does not
love i mean i'm sorry if a woman does
not love the man you are trying to
create
i'm saying you know you know what i'm
saying like a wealthy woman if she
doesn't love a man yeah if a wealthy
woman doesn't love a man she's going to
wind up
she's going to wind up cheating she's
going to wind up straining so she's
going to wind up you know what i'm
saying like so just the probability
right so just when we look at them or
she's going to want to have an emotional
sticker or there's just maybe maybe not
maybe can i just
i'm going to read you a quote that i
once heard you tell me a woman's loyalty
is tested when her man has nothing
but a man's loyalty is tested when he
has everything
do you see what i'm saying yeah maybe
this goes down to the concept of
hypergamy yeah if when a woman looks at
her man and he's not bringing anything
to the table she's like i'm out but when
a man's like dude i got this that the
other
huh yeah that's exactly what you're
doing this is what i'm saying i mean
this is this is what i feel but i do
hear what you're saying if a woman is in
a relationship with a man and she is
wealthy that the the probability of that
is not really high because men just make
more money than women you know in this
country so we're talking about some very
limited statistics because there's just
not a whole lot of it does it exist yes
it does um could she end up in a
loveless marriage could the woman end up
in a loveless marriage it really depends
on what you're marrying for i think
that's one of the fundamental issues in
this country with people don't
understand that marriage was created for
family this is what it's created for so
when you talk about these love and
emotions it's great when it's at it but
you were coming together for a family
agree with you i have a friend that got
married and they were like yeah we're
not having kids right i'm like what the
[ __ ] are you getting married before what
historical reference are you ready
but
to protect wealth from wealthy families
exactly that's what it is
yeah it was like i'm a king sen i'm a
senator my prince that's what marriage
is great exactly exactly it was it was
created for it to protect to keep the
rich rich right right in the family
family started having sex with each
other family members to maintain wealth
exactly so
i think though people some people get
married even though even if they don't
want children i agree with you by the
way i think that marriage really when
people decide to get married oftentimes
because they want a family and they want
the family doesn't always ability
children you know what i'm saying right
but you don't win what do you mean it
doesn't always mean because it doesn't
like say for instance you just use an
example i'm sorry to cut into you but
you know if someone gets together and
you love this woman and this is this
woman becomes your family there needs to
be documentation in place to make sure
that you know if you're going to leave
your wealth to her that she's you know
that that whatever you generated that
it's shared between you two so this
needs some level of documentation you
know you don't want if you get sick if
if she has to come to the hospital any
of these different things you don't also
build this up what percentage of
marriage
of marriage married couples have no kids
what percentage do you think it is
probably 15 small do you think that high
yeah i think what percentage of married
couples
have no kids it's like 12 percent i
would say
this is fun this is like
12 15. 12 15. what do you think 15 i'm
going 50 saying 15 yeah i say way lower
than that okay why get married
here it is because you're building a
life with someone
how much
29. 29
yeah because adam just yes because
you're building something with someone
29 of the jurors have no kids
what are you doing i don't get it it's
not just security it's not just security
what do you want
i mean you got to be a
why
what who do
the it's an act of love there needs to
be something
like for you
to say all right till death do us part
and just be with one woman the rest of
your life as a man but you have no kids
nothing whatsoever i've seen it i don't
understand that concept i've seen i have
a few friends in mind and like i get
they're doing it and i
more power to you i love these people i
it just doesn't
so like something doesn't make sense
you're not building a life with someone
if you're not if you're i mean what
you're building a life yeah to do it
what about that
point of building a life in a family is
that kids it's not about family for
everybody sometimes it's about a family
like let me ask you a jedi you've been
married how long now i'm married four
years okay how long do you think your
marriage would last with jeremy if you
had no kids
i wouldn't be worried about that one bit
what are you talking what what i
wouldn't people do
but what about the people that are
together and they can't procreate
together you'd adopt a kid
what if you don't want children not
everybody wants children there's many
people here i don't get that then don't
get married like you mean marriage is to
have a family and create a legacy and
like you're defining your family
you think i need someone to family only
is children you only see family as
children not just about it's not just
it's not it's not it's not just guys if
you're out there just marrying a chick
without and just adam you're settling
down with one woman in the restaurant
all three disagreements
that's fine you also have a terrible
view of marriage what you just said
because you just said what do i need to
come home and have someone complain to
me that's not marriage isn't just that
it's somebody to lean on you know
whatever i must not have a terrible idea
of marriage because 70 percent of people
understand they're on myself
mathematically i don't know you don't
know why those people don't have kids
maybe some of them can't hide that's
still 28 percent of 29 of people getting
my feeling is if the man used to
reference the man
feels it in his heart to say i'm gonna
show
a greatest act of love that i can to you
of loyalty and security and just uh
to show the rest of the world how much i
love you i'm going to marry you
that has nothing to do with children
that's that's him demonstrating his uh
his highest act of love to her based on
what she desires or he desires by the
way we're cool with that i'm on the same
page i've been in love i've been like
like 100 percent i don't necessarily
agree with it but then
all right that's it we're done like just
the two of us i i don't understand that
confidence but sometimes people uh
sometimes men don't want you with anyone
else like sometimes men get married
because they love you so much and they
don't want you no that's called jealousy
no that's called having a fragile ego no
that's not
you because i don't want anyone else
touching you that's part of that
percentage too though yeah but why would
you yeah adam we gotta talk after this
show i don't know i'm talking on the
show this is true
teach me why i'm wrong can i just say
one thing like life is full of hills and
valleys right everyone's been through
obstacles everyone's been through tough
times there are people who want a
partner they want to go through life and
say you know what i may lose a parent i
may have a friend that winds up in the
hospital trauma is gonna hit every
single one of us have been through
totally understanding partner then why
get married because they just have a
living girlfriend commitment because
that living girlfriend can walk away so
the woman can take half your [ __ ] when
you when you can't uh because it's
different to be invested in someone and
have
i'm going to make a bet i'm going to
make a bet with you in your life you're
going to change your mind about this
about what about what you're saying i
guarantee you
when i get married because i want to get
married it's because i want to have a
family with this woman okay guys and i'm
going gonna say this is the reason that
we're i'm buying you this expensive ring
and we're getting this big house is
because i want to have a family if you
think i'm just marrying you because i
love you and i'm just wishing on a star
they're gonna have some dream life and
i'm just gonna have someone to share
life with that's not how i view marriage
that's you right there's a lot of people
seventy percent of people agree with me
lady i actually agree because a lot of
people agree with you because i would
not get married outside of the creation
of children so i i do understand you but
i also know that that is not the only
reason for people to get married even
though that's my place i i believe that
you're not married
for me to marry you would have to be you
know for co-creation would you have
gotten married
and had no kids
probably not the kind of person i am
would you have gotten married and had no
kids uh at that moment in time
we had she wasn't going to marry me
unless i agreed to kids so that was
actually a deal break okay
yeah meaning and i respect that from her
so um to which yeah i agreed and uh you
know who knows how different things
would have been if we were just waiting
and having kids okay
i noticed you didn't ask me no i'm
coming to you but i've already asked you
exactly i said i said would you have
married jeremy if you didn't want to
have i got married and i was leaning
toward not wanting kids i got married
because i am that person i wanted a
partner in life above all else i'm very
grateful i'm glad i had a kid it's the
best thing but there's also two sides to
the to the coin
jeremy has an opinion here too jeremy
wanted a family
jeremy but jeremy so
but he would have gotten he would have
before you gotten married did you have a
conversation about the family we were
going to get married of course but you
said i don't want kids you'd be like no
probably out of here no because i said i
don't know how i feel about this and he
said you know what i want to get married
anyway it's about us i want a
partnership i want to do this life with
you and if we have kids great it's an
added bonus so if you like that clip
click right here to watch another or if
you want to watch the entire saucecast
click right here
[Music]